[Musique]
c'est parfait messieurs j'espère vous
êtes satisfait je pense que par contre
nos téléspectateurs devraient pas besoin
de se demander ce qu'il se porte
non rassurez-vous nous nous sommes
d'abord peut-être en train de voir votre
santé après tout ce serait gentil mais
c'était à nos techniciens qui
aujourd'hui pour autoriser vraiment à
vous présenter sa recette ont été ont bu
l'apéritif que leur a offert vraiment
car vous le savez où vous ne le savez
pas il est interdit de dire dans un
studio de télévision comme de cinéma
derrière de prononcer le mot ficelles
alors comme aujourd'hui rennes on nous
présente la recette du boeuf à la
ficelle il fallait se décider et ma foi
c'est fait c'est là bien vous allez
pouvoir le dire mais tant vous voudrez
pendant toute l'émission
alors je crois que ce sera 10 et bien
voilà bien là on commence que maintenant
je vais laissez nous faire notre boeuf à
la ficelle si je mens que beaucoup de
choses
d'abord je m'en vais enlever ici un
morceau et ses filières qui a cuit mais
qui n'est pas le boeuf à la fia qui est
simplement un morceau nous en reparlons
tout à l'heure alors vous avez fait pour
nous avoir le pot-au-feu
maintenant que nous avons obtenu c'est
un véritable autorité en bouillon de
pot-au-feu dans le bouillon pot-au-feu
nous allons mettre de l'aiguillette ce
morceau d'aiguillettes qui lui et le
peuple haïtien alors le voici
nous allons compter 20 minutes de
cuisson
je regarde bon alors ici nous avons un
outil anti ce défilé s'ils ont le kers
nous avons mis des légumes nous allons
la tâche et moi je l'imaginais fait rien
vous emporterez 1 et puis si vous n'avez
pas au fond on savait aussi s'en passer
sa cible c'est là c'est pourquoi je
préfère le vous verrez pourquoi mes
réponses énorme bouquet le poireau je
m'excuse mais s'il a eu déjà des légumes
avant il ya eu tous les lakers corps le
coup on recommence on remet autant de
légumes que nous avons nous aurions mis
normalement dans un pot-au-feu
alors on va faire avec un double
consommer ou alors qui va il va se
trouver il va se trouver avant intégrant
les deux fois et c'est nécessaire
derrière alors as you know nyon piqué
est pas avec les colocs et voici du
sélery le tout en attendant laissez
bouillir ça va repartir tout de suite et
nous allons nous occuper maintenant de
garniture
1 comment dirais-je la façon de la
préparer la garniture à nouveau 20
minutes de cuisson vous avez mis de
l'aiguillé de l'aiguillé en aiguille on
peut mettre à peu près tout les dinars
ôter tout dollars au tir n'est ce pas
vous avez bien compris il vient à retire
son possible pour faire du des boeufs à
l'affiché lors que dans l'opération à
montceau de moto fait on aurait même pu
sur un évolue le maître queux des eaux
n'est ce pas les carcasses où vous le
souhaitez
par exemple un bouillon un très bon
consommer avec les carcasses de volaille
oui ça aurait fait avec également
alexander semin et c'est excellent
qu'aux mais naturellement nous pourrons
nous serions mais n'en ferai pas
traditionnellement à l'occasion
j'ai mis ton l'aiguillette voyez vous ça
ne s'est pas arrêté de bruit roues du
moins pas beaucoup j'aurais pouvoir le
congrès en maintenant dans quelques
secondes
parce que j'ai la sécurité du de
l'ébullition wii est ici voyez où j'ai
fait que des pommes de terre alors les
pommes de table effectuera pas je les
fais jamais cuisant louis instaure le
consommer qui qui est destiné à être
utilisé par que par contre si je voulais
je pourrais très bien faire cuire les
pommes de terre dans du consommer
prélevé ici n 1 serait que meilleure
alors là je couvre ça pour le moment
soyez je vous parlais de la mois alors
voici un an ça moi pour faire cuire la
moelle de cette hausse il ya deux
méthodes que nous allons parler des deux
méthodes la première oui
la première consiste à prendre de
rondelle comme ceux ci de pommes de
terre ou de carottes en l'occurrence de
la carte et voyez où nous allons mais
ton bout de ficelle cette opération en
vue d'empêcher la moelle de sang à
l'aide de partir n'est pas de tomber
dans le consommer essayant on doit pas
la retrouver
alors là je les décris
je lui file offrait alors là vous avez
peur d'une mauvaise habitude pour la
prochaine fois la roja est attaché ça
comme ceci non non je préviens vous
aider parce que c'est vous faire affront
non voilà je trouve pas là alors ça nous
allons le plonger si vous le
récupèrerons tout à leur disant que ça
m'attire et combien de sa moelle dans
cette recette mais alors là vous allez
voir c'est une question de goût en
réalité et on pénètre en titre s'envole
de cette grandeur là à peu près par
personne ou même un peu plus petits
c'est à dire la moitié de ça alors là je
suis là je m'en avait jamais les
services et satisfaits et je m'attache
également cette 6ème comme j'ai fait
toutes les infos de la semaine le nombre
et le moins possible à la poignée à la
poignée pour les récupérer très
facilement
voilà alors ceci maintenant le présente
plus de difficultés le rapport à des
légumes alors les légumes de garnitures
sont classiques ceci étant un peu moins
classiques
il ya donc des poireaux dans le vert
n'est ce pas par exemple on peut garder
on peut faire ceci lorsque l'on fait le
consommer le premier consommé dans
lequel on fera cuire le boeuf à la
ficelle par la suite on peut utiliser
les déchets des légumes qui serviront
par la suite à faire le second consommer
alors ça vous vous expliquer comment ça
paraît que c'est que maintenant
l'émission de danone en balance et cela
simplement la démonstration de ce qu'ils
sont ce qu'ils sont alors voici et faro
dont nous avons mis tous les verts pour
faire le premier consommateur
alors voici ici des carottes et des
navets pour ses quarante essais
n'avaient nous les avons tourné alors là
je vais vous expliquer ce que c'est que
de tourner des légumes est la raison
pour laquelle on peut ne pas gaspiller
ne rien gaspiller c'est à dire faire le
premier consommer avec les débris des
légumes pôle emploi après alors le
tournage de légumes consiste surtout à
leur donner une forme à l'opinion
attendez tous et pas du tout le même
genre de buy-in tiens c'est le même
thème c'est le même terme exact ça c'est
une façon de maudit c'est une façon de
modeler à l'oreille de la coupe élabore
ses légumes à des grosseurs a
pratiquement égal pour par la suite vous
allez voir on les tourne et d'en faire
de leur enlever
bon eh bien ce tournage ou non le père
de simone une assiette dans laquelle je
vais laisser tomber les épluchures et
une autre dans laquelle je mettrai les
légumes tournée et voilà merci alors le
tournage des légumes s'opère comme ceux
ci coûtent aux moyens dans la main
droite
on tourne comme ce soir on n'a pas fait
ce mouvement en arrondi et voici ce que
l'on obtient on obtient des légumes
comme ceux ci qui sont tournés alors
croyez on en enlève là tout le bloc de
la carotte qui n'est pas bon et spa qui
a fait le moins bon que le rouge en
profite ce entre 200 et en donne la
forme aux légumes on leur donne une
force égale alors tous et toutes ces
futures que je suis en train de fès
seront serrés sont utilisés pour le
premier bouillon
car il s'agit de légumes épluchés comme
vous pouvez le voir je dirais plus cher
c'est une façon de parler de réduire
parure car il s'agit de paris il s'agit
de parer les légumes que de leur donner
une forme légale
alors voici comment tourner des carottes
comme on tourne bien avait on donne en
mouvement au couteau et ce sont ces
régula qui sont dans votre petit dans le
petit qui est à l'enjeu ou expliquer les
raisons pour laquelle on les met dans un
filet ce qui n'est pas une nécessité
absolue
c'est une obligation certaine quand vous
allez vous voir les sortir ce sera vive
et ouais c'est bien vous avez
immédiatement trouvé la solution
bien sûr j'ai alors là oui je continue
en fait à quelques-uns uniquement pour
que l'on voit bien comment ça se faire
oui il s'agit donc de donner une forme
pour légumes mais cette forme n'est pas
tellement elle est esthétique bien
entendu l'esthétique joue mais c'est
surtout la régularité c'est à dire de
faire des légumes qui sont écroués bien
tout ça catherine me paraît extrêmement
qui pertinents or donc avoir fini jeudi
à carottes navets poireaux sellerie non
le céleri gemmerlé chez vous verrez
d'ailleurs talent chariot et les pommes
de terre elles ont également tourné des
films merveilleux
on a donc la possibilité de préparer ses
légumes avant on aura les gars là
pendant les deux ou trois heures de
cuisson nécessaire on les met au fréon
les méninges mouiller pour pas qu'ils
qui se fait tristement mais ce n'est pas
grave ce qu'on attend de vous dire j'ai
un pot-au-feu
oui c'est ça et puis on va mais oui mais
oui ah oui alors oui ça évidemment ces
diamants alors non alors c'est là où
justement je vais vous démontrer que non
ça ne se ressemblent pas bon je vais si
vous voulez
ceci alors je veux m'en servir ceci
étant il est mis alors je vous faire
voir tous les pommes de terre menant
alors les pommes de terre ou le rang les
tournées beaucoup plus grosse amende
je n'ai besoin de journalistes à port
louis où là nous allons tous paient les
deux bourgs des pommes de terre comme
ceux ci lors les tournées voici comment
on tourne une pomme de terre
alors beaucoup plus grosse vous savez
tout ce qui est en guinée on donne la
forme également un ballon de rugby voilà
la ponote est retourné en réalité vaio
elles n'ont pas besoin ces pommes qui
sont des ponts nouvelle d'être tournée
elles sont déjà très régulière mais
c'est néanmoins pour la démonstration
que je le fais ce n'est pas une utilité
il faut bien faire quelque chose pendant
que ça cuit aussi mais ce challenge et
de quoi faire d'aller voir de quoi faire
j'ai beaucoup de choses à faire rêver à
trois complété à seulement pour vous
faire voir comment on tourne une pomme
de terre
vous étiez d'ailleurs déjà bien servi
parce qu'elle avait déjà des formes
alors là voyez vous en êtes également on
ne doit pas perdre
oui j'étais bien j'avais on le doit oui
oui alors ceci ses épluchures donc
servir à faire un petit potager une
petite purée quelque chose en tout cas
on ne doit pas les jeter
on doit s'en servir pour faire quelque
chose
en tout cas le potage c'est très très
bien ceci ne joue plus et bien catherine
nous allons parler si vous voulez des
hausses en grâce pour l'enlever ce que
ça doit maintenant tout ça si vous
voulez nous allons parler des ensembles
l'os à moelle que voici
il ya deux façons de l'utiliser la façon
de vous démontrer tout à l'heure que
vous ai montré tout à l'heure et une
seconde façon qui est extrait à la
moelle et de cuire la moelle à part
alors voici comment ici comment on
extrait la moelle des os en mai l'osce
comme ceux ci nous un petit coup sec la
honte et tout s'éclaire et voici la
moelle extraites de l'osce en principe
on doit arriver à la voir à presque
entière si vous voyez vos missions
voilà vous suis là et bien venu sans la
santé on croyait
ça n'a rien à voir avec la moelle
épinière mais il s'agit pas d'une
vraiment les punir les amours et bien
[Musique]
voilà bon eh bien nous allons ceci est
terminé
nous allons parler un petit peu de la
passion de poche et 7 mois de la cuire
car elle est pourquoi n'avez-vous vers 3
l'aviez vu vous n'en aviez mis 15 ans à
moins d'un mètre
oui ça va jouer un rôle maintenant oui
nous allons faire quelque chose qui est
légèrement en dehors de cette question
mais qui va aller avec
mais qui va aller à la ficelle
exactement alors ceci nous mettons nous
devrions couper dans nous devrions
d'abord mettre cette moelle dans de
l'eau et du sel pendant environ 24
heures mais elle est très belle elle est
très fraîche par conséquent nous allons
immédiatement l'utiliser ce qui n'est
pas impossible
pourquoi de l'eau salée si on le met
dans l'eau c'est pour cela des gorges
alors là nous allons couper ou ses
passions les vrais fès le coup dans
l'eau que bunge côté un petit peu
colorées qu'on voyait il ya des roses et
alors là nous allons mettre et moi
immédiatement comme ceci sans titre en
titre ont d'elle dans de l'eau j'ai bien
dit de l'eau froide ou chaude valbuena
seul un bandage à sa de la laisser cuire
le temps nécessaire c'est à dire très
peu de temps ici on est que tant
qu'elles soient non non il ne faudra pas
vous allez voir elle va puis elle va
vouloir la faire bouillir elle va cuire
exemple bon et bien ça c'est terminé
nous allons nous occuper si je voulais
qu il tenait pendant que ça ça va cuire
du petit panier pardon quelques minutes
nous allons simplement surtout à
vérifier et nous nous rendre compte de
côté alors notre petit fils est là bas
notre petit filet je regarde un peu ce
qui se passe ou ce gentil de me donner
les 20 minutes 4 et les 20 minutes à
partir du moment où j'ai commencé à
mettre les viandes de notre bon ici du
pain de mie
rien de plus banal que ce monsieur
me paraît un petit peu parce qu'il est
sec et je vais couper deux tranches de
plaine
c'est dangereux ennemi alors je pars et
un coq type comme ceci mais sur ce volet
ses titres quel moment ça va
c'est prévu là nous allons les mettre de
côté
nous allons nous en servir tout à
l'heure à l'eau et au savon alors
maintenant nous allons baisser le feu il
n'est pas nécessaire que ça vous trop
qu'est-ce que vous voilà
eh bien nous allons parler maintenant de
ce fameux pot-au-feu tout à l'heure je
réponds 2 oignons ce mois ci qu'elle du
premier du premier quart du premier que
l'on a vécu à la veille façon de le
malaise face à ce qu'il ait pas l'air
d'être trop pot-au-feu
alors là nous allons prendre des oignons
que nous allons couper en voilà un
oignon car le poteau de ce qu'on a fait
cuire la peur la panique non pour le
moment engagé projet qu'il ait pas
manger avec l'équipe web vous allez lui
faire subir une préparation
nous allons voir comment on peut
l'employer qui n'est pas trop les autres
il ya encore 5 minutes de quatre minutes
pour votre aiguille est bon et bien
c'est parfait
je voudrais donc ici je vais passer m
ceci tu vas continuer approcher et ici
vous allez me donner l'huile je vous
prie catherine quand il pleuvait par
l'otan c'est sa merci il y en a c'est si
vous voulez c'est un peu de beurre
j'ai peur voilà et ses oignons de temps
qu'est ce que vous préparez la kiffe
avait préparé un petit boeuf au gratin
un petit boeuf mironton urgent d'y venir
le beau-fils elle est en train de cuire
il faut le valais temps alors pour
passer notre temps agréablement
nous allons donc faire quelque chose me
dit je retravaille 28 ans 20 minutes
fait fissa c'est donc bien oui c'est une
viande rouge absolument sûrs c'est une
viande sur les enseignants vient de
saignante qui est tout de même cuite
dans de l'eau quand tant de l'eau dans
du bon consommé ici alors émincés
quelques cornichons comme ceux ci en
carrière non mais c'est pas vous
justement à bons petits oignons alors
oui c'est le laisse tomber on
l'attendait et puis je vais chercher ce
bon voilà et le flat dans lequel il est
qui va d'ailleurs me servir alors voyons
je voudrais me faire un tout petit peu
de place que très tard et un peu de
place je crois que j'ai ma progression
ici la voilà et ce plan va me servir
tous à l'heure oui c'est parfait de
trois minutes je serai frais
envoyez-vous ici peut enlever la graisse
c'était quoi vous aviez pris la sas est
un morceau caprins et puis je vais
couper le beurre comme ceux ci en
tranches et eau
l'arcade race et nous voulons voilà je
vais le ranger comme ceux ci dans ce
crash allez vous conserver les titres
pendant ce temps là les petits oignons
rissoles ces petits oignons ruisseau
tout ça est en train de cuire très bien
juste un peu d'huile et les oignons
c'est tout l'huile et l'oignon rouge est
donc suffisamment et vini salini poivre
exactement 4 et ça fait tout ça était
cuit avec des assaisonnements suffisante
sais d'où je mets ici les cornichons
dessus comme cela et je continue à
occuper ici des oignons qui sont
maintenant très blonds comme vous pouvez
le constater je suis presque tenir pas
trop mais au sens pendant ils sont
beaucoup voulaient voir un tiers de
l'est le vinaigre de vos pré carré bon
alors ici je m'en vais mouiller avec du
vinaigre doucement
un peu de vinaigre conséquences sur les
nombreux beaucoup non mais j'ai pas en
venir si je vais laisser bouillir 1
ajoutant quand on s'appelle comment
c'est peut-être cette source là ça
s'appelle ambiante
merci 4 et la voilà je vais laisser
cuire cela quelques minutes
pendant ce temps là j'aimerais faire
griller se passe votre viande est très
chaude ou froide l'a fait les choses
réelles les sorties mais on pouvait le
faire également visa vient de 3 c ce qui
me semble être prise qu'au japon
alors voici si le père a grillé comme ça
ça m oui simplement le tourner une fois
et puis nous allons préparer maintenant
carrément le bafa la fission si vous
voulez cour des grands c'est fini allons
nous en occuper pendant que ça va
continuer alors ici dans ce dîner quand
je le laisse presque complètement dit
réduit et je vais ajouter un tout petit
peu ces tomates de tomates comme cela
voilà mélanger comme quoi vous nous avez
donné la façon d'utiliser les deux est
ce que nous avons fait cuire la veille
des jeux s'est terminée cette scène ça
ressemblera vraiment pas du tout bon
donc je regarde le pain qui est enfin
ouvert il est très fort bon ici c'est
terminé je mets ce si sûr le bref comme
ceux ci ne vaux et je soupire très
largement de fromage grillé et nous
allons mettre seul à gratiner
tranquillement pendant que le document
note chose alors voilà nos deux tranches
de pain
n'est ce pas que nous avons placé sur
ça s'est posée puis celle c'est pour le
bâti siens si longue que je veux dire
par là que ça pourrait être fait
isolément l'a9 royaume ici je voulais
une assiette je voterai et une petite
écumoire je vais égouttez la moelle qui
accuse maintenant voyez vous il est
devenu très transparente
elle est donc huit et sept mois ne fait
absolument partie de la recette elle
fait partie de la recette en ce sens que
nous pouvons assaisonner accompagner
notre boeuf à la ficelle deux mois vous
pouvez l'enlever en stationnaire par
abonnement voilà et bien maintenant nous
allons même sept mois égoutter sur les
postes comme ceci sans prendre de
précautions spéciales et nous allons la
saison assaisonner de poivre seulement à
yéo parce que c'est sale et ça crie ça
vite alors nous le poivron fortement et
nous allons mettre ceux-ci pardon et
tous les diamants les ça servira à côté
ouais mais les morceaux sur enfin allons
nous mettons à ceux ci également aux
responsables espèrent maintenant si vous
voulez me donner le grand plat catherine
qui est ici au bout voilà alors nous
allons couper sortir le bref le coupé au
père voit ici nous avons des serbes
vous enlevez les légumes veut enlever
les légumes est ce qu'on valait
serviront vallée oui oui oui nous allons
les mettre à côté
le butin dans les gardes se vous prie
tous
tous tous tous merci
voici ici nous allons mettre certains de
ceux-ci nous allons prendre le filet à
papillons qui l'épuisé l'ouvrir on se
sert de ça toute sa vie en quelque sorte
un arc
j'attends une fois et puis toute sa vie
on en a on peut faire des légumes ainsi
atteint parce que vraiment ils se sont
alors ils ne sont pas écrasés plus dans
vos sorties en quelques secondes ça vaut
la peine ça c'est très astucieux voici
également les services et les riches
elle doit sortir l'avion
nous allons d'abord sentir le plan comme
ceci pour pouvoir bien voir vous les
voulez mettre ici le plat pour que je
puisse couper la viande etc on voit
combien elle est jolie et saignante à la
alors ici elle est cuite voyez vous il
ya plus de 20 minutes qu'il est au fond
alors nous allons en sortir
la coupe est vraiment c'est exactement
comme ça qu'il faut qu'elle soit et même
une fois découpées là vous n'avez pas
d'autres c'est un immense absolument
alors une petite seconde ici pour donner
la couleur
j'en sais pas si vous voyez à quel point
elle est impeccable et alors nous allons
remettre la viande ici comme s'offrir à
plat il y en avait trop la voilà le plat
ici dessus je tiens à lui de mettre là
le plat ici nous allons aller chercher
se passe-t-il dans le courrier
j'entends des petits bruits voilà le
gratin d'ipswich les toasts à la moelle
que voilà et bien voilà catherine nous
avons donc utilisé le bouille qui nous
avait servi à faire le premier consommer
à j'ai oublié quelque chose et vous ne
me l'avait pas demandé qu'est ce que
j'ai dans le ciel que c'est mal excusez
moi les pommes de terre nous allons donc
utiliser le premier buzz qui avait servi
vos pot-au-feu qui celui là est une
firme pour pot-au-feu
c'est sam l'avons utilisé d'une façon
fort sympathique et qui n'a donc rien à
voir on fait intégrateurs genre de
l'obligataire mironton et puis c'est
finalement le 2 à l'aller c'est qu'on va
manger à la manière du poteau à la
manière des potes que sa vie avec tous
les légumes du pot-au-feu mais un bug
très saignant comme vous pouvez le voir
qu'à puis 20 minutes dans un consommé
déjà très concentré et que nous avons
ensuite ajoutés dans le cadre a encore
ajouté
2 les nouveaux légumes de nouveau tout
ce qui était nécessaire donc il y a plus
la mois le coup leur ont servi en même
temps ce qui ne gâche rien ou dans notés
bon et il faut rappeler peut-être ça
échappé à nos amis que c'est de
l'aiguillette que vous recommander pour
ça oui c'est de l'aiguillette sinon ce
n'est pas que ça je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure que tout de tous les martyrs
pouvait faire du boeuf à la piste mais
que l'aiguillette évidemment
réussissaient mieux que n'importe
laquelle
et pour l'autre va utiliser normalement
du def pot-au-feu
eh bien chers amis au revoir et bon
appétit
[Musique]